[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle semaine d'information
locale sur tv 78 bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez pour ce journal de la
rédaction
voici les titres de ce lundi 8 juin
après 82 jours de fermeture le site a
rouvert ses grilles au public ce
week-end le parc et le château de
versailles sont accessibles de nouveau
en raison du contexte sanitaire la
visite se fait uniquement sur
réservation envers nous étions sur place
elles ont repris leur fonctionnement
depuis le 4 mai les sept déchetteries de
saint quentin en yvelines se sont
adaptés pour accueillir les habitants
axé sur rendez vous seulement respect
strict des gestes barrières reportage et
puis les files d'attentes étaient
nombreuses en ce premier rendez vous
festif poste déconfinement pour la fête
des mères les fleuristes ont été pris
d'assaut ce dimanche
exemple dans une enseigne installée à
elancourt nous parlerons également tout
à l'heure de cette mission parlementaire
confiée à une députée des yvelines
natalia pouzy ref pour lutter contre le
phénomène des rodéos urbains
il est l'un des monuments les plus
connus au monde et sa réouverture et et
est très attendue depuis samedi les
visiteurs peuvent de nouveau parcourir
le domaine du château de versailles un
accès uniquement sur réservation au vert
pour réguler les flux sens de
circulation et masque obligatoire à
partir de 11 ans dans les parties
intérieures dans les jardins des
franciliens essentiellement qui
pouvaient visiter les lieux dans un
calme assez inhabituel les touristes
étrangers étaient effectivement absent
avec des frontières encore fermer le
site qui est resté confiné quasiment
pendant trois mois 82 jours exactement
lé réactions glanées au micro de manon
varaldo est venu exprès parce que voilà
le château de versailles réouvre
là on attendait ça avec impatience on
vient ainsi régulièrement sur le château
et on voulait venir justement faire des
photos des fontaines
et de l'ambiance de versailles qui
réouvre piaffaient d'impatience pour
revenir évidemment aujourd'hui on a fait
le tour du grand canal comme on fait
quasiment toutes les semaines c'est
super bien entretenu c'est magnifique
c'est agréable de se balader balaye tout
va trés beau aujourd'hui mais d'avoir de
l'eau est si bas les deux tours de l'eau
c'est sympa quoi c'est très joli
et c'est extraordinaire d'aller là je
rêvais d'aller ici mais aujourd'hui je
suis là un très très bon en été mais
mais en arrivant m'attendais à ouverture
donc ça cesse et c'est merveilleux on va
pouvoir profiter de tous ces espaces
super bruit j'ai bien lu mon impression
de ceux des consignes est vraiment à
rejoindre la vie qui reprend donc peu à
peu un semblant de normalité dans les
yvelines où l'épidémie de coronavirus a
confirmé son recul ce week end est les
patients hospitalisés et continue de
diminuer il s'établissait hier à 500 du
jamais vu depuis la fin mars
ce week-end le nombre de réanimation est
resté stable
on a enregistré en revanche quatre décès
supplémentaires dans le département le
virus a fait 500 deux victimes à
l'hôpital depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire 1986 personnes ont été guéries
d'une forme sévère de lakovic 19 et dans
l'actualité également cette hausse
constatée des rodéos urbains depuis le
confinement pour contrer le phénomène le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner a lancé un plan d'action il a
confié une mission à deux députés dont
l'une des yvelines elle natalia pouzy
réf
interrogé par mathilde et demi bonsoir
nathalie abou zahab vous êtes débuté la
république en marche dans la sixième
circonscription des yvelines alors le
ministre d'intérieur christophe castaner
vous arrive
récemment confié avec la députée
catherine o som la mission d'élaborer un
plan d'action pour lutter contre la
recrudescence des rodéos urbains
quelles vont être vos pistes de travail
bonsoir
eh bien je crois que la loi a donné les
bases pour caractériser un délit ces
comportements dangereux et maintenant il
faut avoir une vision plus globale on ne
peut pas toujours
procéder à des flagrants délits et donc
je pense que c'est en lien avec les élus
locaux la police municipale et bien sûr
police nationale gendarmerie que nous
pouvons appréhender mieux le phénomène
dans sa globalité et je pense notamment
au fait de de renforcer la capacité
d'anticiper ces rodéos puisque comme je
vous le disais on ne peut pas toujours
agir en flagrant délit donc c'est en
renforçant leur enseignement aller coûte
aussi des quartiers de voir comment ça
se passait et peut-être d'y intégrer
aussi les associations qui suivent
notamment le jeune public donc le
renseignement la surveillance et
renforcer les capacités d'investigation
pendant continûment l'hérault de urbains
ont augmenté de 15% en créant parfois
des rassemblements illégaux
comment agir face à ces grands groupes
oui alors la loi prévoit aussi de
pénaliser les instigateurs de tels
rassemblements et c'est vrai que là
c'est un phénomène nouveau
comme la route étaient désertés par les
usagers habituels qui étaient confinés
chez eux et qu'ils ne prenaient plus les
routes
certains se sont cru que voilà la route
était ouvert pour faire ce qu'on appelle
des run sur des routes nationales voire
sur des autoroutes ça c'est un
comportement qui cherchent à provoquer
et qui est complètement inacceptable
parce que éminemment dangereux pour tous
les autres usagers de la route et et qui
cherchent le contact avec les forces de
police
et ça ce n'est pas acceptable et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut par le renseignement
essayez de d'arrêter d'en de wii 2 que
ce que ces rodéos ne se produise avant
avant que le rassemblement ait pris son
départ
vous avez été rapporteur de la
proposition de loi en 2018
donc le rodéo urbain est devenu un délit
passible de deux ans de prison et 30000
euros d'amendé
est ce que le plan d'action est il un
complément de cette loi oui c'est
exactement ça s'éteint c'est un
complément nous verrons s'il est
judicieux de renforcer la loi donc sur
telle ou telle plante sur tel aspect
nous verrons aussi l'articulation avec
le judiciaire est adapté je pense que
c'est un point très important pour que
effectivement des tels comportements
soient réprimés et que l'on est un
véritable effet dissuasif à long terme
pour ça il faut que les parquets pour
que la justice suive
faut-il renforcer selon vous la
surveillance et les sanctions dans
certaines villes du coup alors c'est pas
forcément ville par ville
mais je crois qu'il faut vraiment un un
maillage sur nos territoires pour
apprécier les comportements les
phénomènes qui s'y déroulent dans nos
villes ville par ville
et pour arriver à les caractériser il
faut pouvoir faire la différence entre
si vous voulez des jeunes qui vont faire
un peu des bravades face à la police
dans un endroit assez je dirais restera
un périmètre restreint de ceux qui ont
des motos super puissante qui leur
permettent d'acheminer des trafics de
drogue et qui qui n'ont absolument plus
peur de la police c'est c'est voilà il
faut quand même faire une distinction
est forcément adapté le niveau de
sanctions en fonction des dj de la
situation et les contrevenants merci
natalia plus de rêve d'avoir répondu à
nos questions on le rappelle vous êtes
député la république en marche dans les
yvelines et vous êtes donc en charge de
l'élaboration du plan d'action pour
lutter contre la recrudescence des
rodéos urbains
merci m au chapitre des municipales il
n'y aura finalement que trois listes à
guyancourt pour le second tour arrivés
respectivement en quatrième et première
le 15 mars dernier et décidons ensemble
à aiguille en cours menée par olivier
paréja
aiguilles en cours pour tous avec comme
tête de liste le maire sortant françois
morton ont choisi de fusionner les
précisions dans ce sujet de mélanie poké
un choix posés pendant le confinement si
la question de la fusion est apparu dès
le 15 mars
la crise sanitaire a permis aux deux
listes de se rapprocher arrivé en tête
avec 42 % des voix françois morton
intègre 8 membres de la liste d'olivier
paréja ça fait des décennies que les
équipes de guyancourt pour tous et et
les sensibilités écologistes travaillent
ensemble et donc nous nous sommes
retrouvés tout à fait naturellement
en s'apercevant mais ce n'était pas
vraiment une surprise que nos programmes
sont très convergent et que nous avions
déjà de toute façon travaillé ensemble
durant ce mandat issu de la liste
majoritaire lors des élections
municipales de 2014 olivier parent et
j'avais quitté le groupe en cours de
mandat il a choisi sur ce scrutin de
créer sa propre liste le 15 mars dernier
il était crédité de 16% des suffrages
dans les idées qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé pendant la campagne il y avait
la démocratie participative et donc on
avait mis en avant les groupes actions
projets qui sont des des regroupements
des habitants des services de la ville
des associations des élus autour d'un
projet pour élaborer même le projet et
c'est cette façon de fonctionner assez
innovante bas c'est quelque chose qui
nous tenait vraiment à coeur des
volontés de fusion partagé par grégory
pape le candidat de nouvel élan à
guyancourt souhaité créer une seule
liste d'union locale le 28 juin prochain
les guyancourt toi devront donc faire le
choix entre la liste du maire sortant
françois morton celle de grégory pape
est ensemble agissons pour guyancourt
mené par rodolphe baril est à partir de
la semaine prochaine retrouvez une série
de débats entre les candidats au second
tour des municipales dans les villes de
saint quentin en yvelines notamment et
des émissions à regarder sur tv 78 ou à
écouter sur les ondes de nos confrères
de radio sensations yvelines un mois
après le début du déconfinement le
trafic des transports est revenu à une
quasi normalité aujourd'hui
depuis ce lundi 7 environ 90% de
l'activité qui a repris en ile de france
elle est très en revanche arrête de
circuler plus tôt 22 heures pour le rer
a et les lignes transilien 23h pour le
rer b une attestation employeur est
toutefois nécessaire pour emprunter ces
transports
certains pour éviter de prendre le bus
ou les trains à préfère le vélo en cette
période de crise sanitaire à saint
quentin en yvelines ils pourront
bénéficier de 43 km de voies dédiées
supplémentaires courant juin
l'agglomération vient de l'annoncer
alors que les aménagements sont en cours
quatre nouvelles pistes sont tracées
elles sont toutes à destination et en
provenance de la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines avec des départs en garde
villepreux les claies de la verrière de
la zone d'activités de trappes elancourt
ou encore de la mairie de magny les
hameaux l'association vélo sky qui
manifestaient samedi avenue du centre à
montigny le bretonneux saluent
l'initiative mais demandent davantage
d'aménagement à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines toujours les
sept déchetteries de l'agglomération
ouvert le 4 mai dernier avec une
nouvelle organisation dans le respect
strict des gestes barrières avec ce
contexte un toujours de crise sanitaire
l objectif permettre de nouveau aux
habitants d'éliminer leurs déchets le
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et de nicolas landry prendre rendez-vous
pour jeter ses déchets la nouvelle règle
pour accéder aux sept déchetteries de
saint quentin en yvelines depuis la
réouverture le 4 mai dernier les
habitants du territoire doivent se
rendre sur une plateforme internet pour
choisir le créneau horaire et la
déchetterie je te renseigner à la mairie
pour savoir comment ça fonctionne et et
après j'ai téléphoné à 50 tard
j'ai pris des rendez vous et voilà
watcha fonctionne très bien exploité par
véolia les employés de ce site ont
adopté les gestes barrières pour
respecter au mieux les règles sanitaires
les consignes bien c'est le respect des
règles sanitaires de venir seul vous
arrivez à une table vous posez votre
carte
l'agent scan la carte sans la toucher et
vous l'apprenez il n'y absolument voilà
on a on a essayé de gérer sans aucun
contact retrait de composteurs de sacs
de déchets verts ou encore facturation
du traitement des déchets pour les
professionnels d'autres services de
nouveau disponible fermé depuis le 17
mars la réouverture était attendue par
les usagers c'est une forte demande déjà
des administrés dont qui se sont
manifestés pour qu'on les ouvre donc ça
c'est la première conséquence donc
quelque part c'est positif parce que ça
veut dire que c'est un outil aujourd'hui
qui est rentré dans les moeurs
le deuxième mandat on l'a bien vu que
sur le porte à porte les gens qui
pouvaient pas évacuer leurs déchets
verts leur chose comme ça on a eu des
deux augmente tonneau de tonnage sur le
porte à porte sur les sept
établissements de l'agglomération plus
de 17 mille tonnes de produits sont
récoltés par an 80% de ces déchets sont
recyclés saint quentin en yvelines où
l'accès à l'île de loisirs sera gratuit
cet été pour les habitants de la
collectivité agglomérations départements
et régions ont donné leur accord en ce
sens il n'y aura donc plus à débourser 5
euros comme à l'accoutumée par voiture
et par entrée du 1er juillet au 31 août
prochain écoutez ses explications
on a eu une crise sanitaire sans
précédent et on sait d'avancé qu'on aura
évidemment beaucoup de familles qui ne
pourront pas partir en vacances
on a donc besoin d'accompagner sur un
plan social et bien les loisirs la cette
période estivale la manière dont on fait
revivre aussi la solidarité entre nous
et naturellement puisque vous familles
ne pourront pas partir en vacances
donner un accès privilégié aux villes de
loisirs paraît être un instrument tout à
fait important pour la période estivale
est donc naturellement on a discuté et
j'ai fait cette proposition pour l'île
des loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
à l'agglomération département à la
région
aujourd'hui ce qui est annoncé et c'est
effectivement la possibilité pour tous
les saint quentinois d'avoir accès au
delà des 3 d'accès gratuit que cette
créature permanence
si vos études rosine de loisirs
toutefois il peut y avoir une réflexion
au delà je sais que de loisir annonce
sur les modalités pratiques aussi de cet
axe est ce qu'il faut la carte de
résident est ce qu'on peut se présenter
dès qu'un justificatif de domicile
les informations sur cette gratuité à
retrouver prochainement sur le site de
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
et puis ce dimanche c'était bien sûr la
fête des mères avec la crise sanitaire
ce fleuriste d'elancourt est resté fermé
durant huit semaines
sa gérante attendait donc avec
impatience le premier rendez vous festif
poste confinement tout comme les clients
venus nombreux pour l'occasion on
revient sur cette journée avec manon
varaldo dehors une longue files
d'attentes pour accéder à la boutique
fleurs et passion mais la patience a
pris le dessus nombreux voulait repartir
avec un bouquet à l'occasion de la fête
des mères en acheter un petit
assortiment de roseaux toutes les
couleurs choisies par les filles en plus
on n'a pas commandé donc que c'était le
jeu lun donc on n'a plus le temps et on
a joué avec les filles
à l'intérieur c'est l'effervescence un
record d'affluence pour cette gérante
c'est un événement important qui demande
beaucoup de préparation pour la gérante
et son équipe que ça dure une semaine et
ce qui se passe là c'est vraiment les
fleurs les plus périssables pour avoir
les fleurs les plus fraîches où on met
en place me prépare les commandes les
bouquets et c'est la fête des mères
c'est la plus grosse est que ça soit en
chiffres en préparation en tant que
préparation en organisation en achats et
des ventes il y en avait
distance d'un mètre signalé dans la
boutique et gels hydro alcooliques à la
caisse
même en pleine crise sanitaire la fête
des mères restent un moment familial
important
je venais acheté un bouquet de fleurs de
saison pour la fête des mères après j'ai
pris une rose aussi pour ma fille dans
cette boutique des enfants parmi eux
ibrahim et ses frères et soeurs
composent un bouquet et 80% des fleurs
proviennent de petits producteurs
un mélange de couleurs de bleu de rouge
deux rouges et deux un petit peu de
violette blanc lorsque c'est la fête
on doit remercier tous les moments en un
week-end cette fleuriste a réalisé son
plus grand chiffre d'affaires de l'année
donc voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci de votre fidélité
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]